يستعد جهاز الأمن الأوكراني لشن
غارة عبر خطوط العدو
في حرب المدفعية والطائرات بدون طيار
والكثير من الإبداع لأنها تبدو
وكأنها لعبة تقريبًا، فهي لعبة صينية مع بعض
الترقيات وبعض الابتكارات مع بعض
السحر بما فيه الكفاية مثل هذه الطائرة بدون طيار المصنوعة خصيصًا
سوف تسافر إلى ما هو أبعد من
خط زاباريتا الأمامي
بحثًا عن نظام دفاع جوي روسي،
وتطير في عمق
أراضي العدو باتجاه بلدة تعد أحد
الأهداف الرئيسية
لخريطة الحديث عن الهجوم المضاد الجنوبي
على الطرف الآخر من الهاتف
وتراقب  نفس الشاشة وحدة مريخية عالية
جاهزة لإطلاق إشارة النداء
لوحدة هذه الطائرة بدون طيار القائد هنا
تذكير بحياته قبل الحرب
عندما كانت هذه الأرض لا تزال أوكرانية الآن
يمكنك أن ترى على الطريق هذه
مركبات روسية تتحرك هذا  هي
نقطة تفتيش يمكن للروس رؤيتها في
ارتفاع التركماك،
لكن الليلة لم يحالفهم الحظ لأن
نظام الدفاع الجوي الذي أرادوا ضربه لم
يعد موجودًا، وقتك في
المنزل الليلة هو حقل يقع على بعد حوالي 15
كيلومترًا شمال خط المواجهة باستخدام
الأضواء الحمراء فقط لتجنب  الكشف عن
أنهم حصلوا على نظرة شاملة
للمعركة أدناه وما يحدث أبعد من المكان الذي
نطاردهم فيه
لبعض الوقت، لدينا بعض النتائج التي
نعرفها أين يختبئون، ونعرف إلى أين
يتحركون، لذا فهي مسألة تتعلق
بالوقت فقط  للعثور عليهم وكل ذبابة
تسجل الطائرة بدون طيار
معلومات ثمينة عن حالة
مركبات وأنظمة الدفاع الروسية التي يتم
نقلها حتى لو كان
نظام الدفاع الجوي الروسي وضباطه الأربعة إلى الخمسة
دون علمهم الليلة، هل
تشعر بخيبة أمل لا لا، نحن لسنا
بخيبة أمل هذا  مصدرنا هو
عملنا وسنواصل
القيام بذلك حتى يقول إنه تم تحرير كل شبر من
الأراضي الأوكرانية
مهما طال الوقت الذي استغرقته
ميليسا بيل سي إن إن في منطقة زاباريتا